the next set of questions are all about
learning Asian languages specifically
Chinese and Japanese princess Gustav
asks when when you're learning Japanese
and Chinese there is a lot of ground to
cover you have to learn characters you
have to invoke up the sounds to grammar
what progression would you suggest so
when you're learning a language well
that's interesting because I always
consider a language language learning as
a holistic process meaning you learn it
as a whole I don't focus too much and
you know I'm learning now I'm learning
vocab down learning pronunciation now I
learned everything at the same time that
said I would say that in the case of
Chinese every language is different
obviously so for example if you have a
method a way to approach languages you
it's a good way to you know to to change
it a little bit of to the language
you're learning now in the case of
Chinese and Japanese there are special
languages obviously because they're
completely different first they're
completely different from a fanatic
point of view secondly you have the
problem of characters now I would say
that in the case of Chinese the most
difficult and challenging aspect of
learning Chinese in general is
pronunciation people have a lot of
problems with tones because they're not
used to tonal languages now for those
who don't know what tonal languages are
you know basically in every language
there are tones we change our pitch so
syllables or different heights depending
on what kind of language etc etc but in
in in Chinese tones actually define
meaning so if you pronounce a word like
ma and you pronounce it like ma there
are two different words and two
different they have two different
meanings mmm now that that is difficult
because it's completely different but I
think that people make it more difficult
than it actually is if you think about
it Chinese themselves they don't know
these things about told to you obviously
yeah if you ask them what kind of tone
is out the third the fourth that I don't
think about it because they learn it by
chance
for example they didn't learn the single
tone so knowing how to pronounce to
learn tones is quite important and
having said that in Chinese I would I
would say that one of the most important
things to do at the beginning of the
very beginning is to focus on pronounce
not only how words and vowels are
produced so tones and and as well as
consonants because there are retroflex
they're called retroflex consonants are
a little bit difficult and then you can
move on to other aspects of the language
well I would say first of all learning
as a whole try to learn it as a whole
you know but focusing pronunciation is
not is not a bad idea because once you
have you got the pronunciation right
everything is easier because grammar is
hmm I wouldn't make the mistake of
calling you know saying that Chinese
grammar is pretty straightforward at a
basic level it's pretty straightforward
when when you move on to intermediate
and advanced it's much more difficult
because Chinese has a different way of
conveying ideas so you have to
completely change the way you express
yourself even if the grammatical
structure is apparently simple but in to
get all of its a pronunciation first
obviously you still learn a language and
then you move on for example to you
create a bond between the sound and the
written language pinging use you know
the other step is try to stick to Pina
first the transliteration you know in
Latin alphabet because it's going to be
much easier and then after 2 or 3 months
you can start learning characters one
more thing then this goes for both
Chinese and Japanese is that the amount
of characters that you can actually
handwrite doesn't has nothing to do with
your fluency you can be fluent in
Chinese without even being able to read
characters if you if you wanted that to
happen but I suggest yet in you know
recognizing characters so being able to
read is an important part if you want to
understand the culture you want to
understand you know it's part of the
culture so recognizing and being able to
read characters is one thing but to
handwrite them is another ability
language learning when we talk about
learning reading listening speaking
there you know we take for credit that
they're all ingrained in our brains and
as native English speakers we I'm sorry
as native speakers we develop all these
abilities at the same time that's why we
can do all of them but as
language if we try to learn another
language you will see that you can learn
to read but not to to understand it
connected speech you know oral speech or
maybe you can you can understand but
you're not able to talk or you can write
something but you're not able to speak
so there's separate things and as I said
Chinese characters reading reading being
able to recognize a Chinese character
and being able to write it are two
different abilities that can be
developed at the same time or it one can
be developed a little bit later and in
the case of Chinese I suggest you
develop it later because it's very time
consuming if what you want is to be able
to write Chinese characters because of
the beauty of it because you love
calligraphy etc then by all means go for
it but remember that at the beginning
it's not a strictly necessary condition
to speak Chinese fluently and and if
your goal is to speak Chinese fluently
first focus on the bond between sound
and and written word focus on
pronunciation focus on words and grammar
and then go for the characters the same
thing is for Japanese it's like
different in the case of Japanese
Japanese pronunciation is much easier
because the phonetical inventory of
sounds the number of sounds different
ounces is not a complicated especially
for italians but in general so on the
one hand pronunciation is not a problem
maybe the pitch in Japanese the pitch is
a little bit different it's it's a
different problem but that has to do
with intonation but I would say with
Japanese focus more on the language
itself on the syntax the the main
challenge for us for classic Europeans
of speakers in the European languages is
the fact that in Chinese in in Japanese
as much as in Korean the syntax is
actually the opposite you know you can
say like I want to go to China because I
like it they say China I like it because
or since I China want gol want it it's
completely different so you have to to
focus on expressing yourself in a very
different way and then you can focus on
pronounce you can refine pronunciation
so you have to so all in all you have to
consider our language as a holistic
process you have to try to tackle
all these aspects at the same time but
in the special case of Japanese and
Chinese you have characters if you want
to learn characters if that is your main
goal start by all means start doing that
immediately but this is one activity on
its own and then obviously you can focus
also on the other aspects of the
language but this is pretty important
this is something very important to say
because I heard so many times I got
asked so many times how many how many
characters do you know and this is like
right like hey are you fluent so that
that was like I never if you know 4,000
characters then you're fluent and it's
absolutely not true
you